your beautiful son Valentino he's two
now right yeah I remember when I um
found out I was having a
boy um and I I'd obviously wanted a girl
um but when I found out I was having a
boy I was a little I was like okay well
I guess it'll be okay cuz you know now I
don't have to like teach them about all
these horrible things in the world and
have to you know spend my
nights you know awake in bed thinking
about are they safe are they okay or you
know cuz there's predators every corner
and I thought having a boy would be
easier but actually I think that's the
mistake that a lot of parents make
because you do have to teach your boys
not to become those
Predators yeah so now I'm resif my
mindset
cuz yeah but I can't even imagine being
a girl mom I I think I'd just have so
much anxiety knowing what I went through